5 25 on your monday morning boy you know
a project is going to be around for a
while when ndot
gives it a logo
so you get the idea that this trop and
i-15 project we're talking about may
really be for real well this is just the
start with easy to deal with lane
restrictions in the early stages all
between the hours of 9 pm and 5 am and
all involving right shoulder and right
lane closures on the southbound 15
between flamingo and trop except for
late wednesday night into early thursday
morning you'll also lose the right lane
of the on-ramp from trop to go
northbound on the 15th ndot describes
all the work as utility and geotechnical
but there's no need to stuff all this in
your already crowded noggin you can go
back and review it all at your leisure
in printed form along with all of our
stories on our website 8newsnow.com
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com